The next material optimization I'd like to talk about are Material Quality Expression Nodes.
Material Quality Expression Nodes allow you to define how your material is going to react or look
based on the shading path, feature level, or quality setting that is selected inside of your project.
The shading path switch allows you to define how your material will react when used on a deferred, forward, or mobile renderer.
This allows you to anticipate things not necessarily being supported instead of the end user receiving an error.
They get a different version of the material that works with the hardware that is available on that platform.
Feature level does something similar, but it allows us to define by feature level, such as Embedded System 2, Embedded System 3, Shader Model 5, or Shader Model 6.
The quality feature switch allows us to define how this material will look when different quality levels are selected inside of the project settings.
With this, we can have a default and then define various materials for low, high, medium, and epic settings.
Depending on your target platform or target platforms, you may or may not need to utilize the shading path, feature level, or quality switch nodes.
However, this is something that you should research for your project, as quality switches enable you to ensure your project will look how you want,
even when run on a platform that might not necessarily have the hardware needed to display your materials in the manner you wish.